continue to wear masks on planes
that's up to them
would you like to appeal the ruling or
the ruling of the judge made striking
down that mandate i haven't spoken to
the cdc yet
president biden reacting as this mask
mandate for planes gets grounded a
federal judge in florida ruling his
administration does not have the
authority to continue enforcing the much
despised rule
so you can now avoid the wrath of being
scolded by the flight attendant in
between sips of vodka i mean water
airports and airlines all over the
country dropping the requirement and
cheers breaking out mid-flight after
passengers heard the news
overturn the mass mandate
my company is
[Music]
a lot of cheers there the end of the
mask mandate could also mean the end to
all those nasty midair fights
with people going jerry springer on each
other over having to cover up
but not so fast the white house not
ruling out a challenge to bring the
mandates back
and of course the media is cheering them
on
just because this ruling was made by a
judge doesn't mean that suddenly the
science has changed what we saw was a
legal decision not a public health
decision guess who's not lifting his
personal mac mask mandate on
airplanes uh i i will not i i ain't
ah they like to they just need to stay
together despite the science dan the one
thing that we keep hearing you know oh
there's mask mayhem and mass chaos how
hard is it you either wear it or you
don't you don't have to this is not no
one's putting a gun to your head you can
still wear it why are you flipping out
it's really incredible to me that the
white house decided to basically
yesterday take the l yeah we're
disappointed in the decision but instead
of like accepting the win
they want to make it all muddled yeah so
you have the president saying well
that's up to them well we have to talk
to the cdc well we're not really sure
instead of just saying the court has
spoken
make good personal choices for yourself
this is march or april of 2022 it's not
march of 2020. we have vaccines we have
therapeutics we have many people that
have natural immunity we also know from
their own emails between fauci and
malinsky that the six feet to slow the
spread was just a number they threw out
there and the airline ceo uh he
testified saying that
what the studies that they've shown is
because the air is recirculated sitting
on a plane right next to somebody
is is like sitting 15 feet away from
them yeah an airplane so the six feet
thing that that's twice that yeah so
they're not following the science
they're not following the politics and
the other thing is don't don't forget it
wasn't the biden administration made
decisive action and the president is
saying i looked at the science and i'm
making a decision and this is where
we're going no the every single time
they get pushed into doing something
it's either by congress or a court right
there's not a lot of decisiveness going
on no you know sean um people like
valerie jarrett says i don't care
whether about i'm still wearing my mask
it seems to me that they've some people
and it's basically on the left side have
latched on to the mask as an identity
component it's like a human bumper
sticker it's like you it would be like
you me going up and saying you need to
take that visualize world peace bumper
sticker off your car that's they feel
like you can't take this mask from me
this is their liberal flag right you put
it on and i show my liberal stripes but
just i gotta tell you what i'm so happy
about this
this being lifted because now all of
america gets to see the beautiful
mustache on her all the time never going
to mask it again it's like we want to
see it right amazing gorgeous look at
the mask i was going to i thought you
were going to bring up the fact that you
how many kids you got you must like when
you got to mask them you got nine kids
it was horrible i don't mask them i
don't feel like that's a whole box yes
such a box of masks but to dana's point
i think the white house actually loves
this ruling they don't have the backbone
to actually make it themselves they're
waiting for a court to do what they
should have done and now they're not
going to appeal this watch they won't do
it nope um and what's frustrating is the
cdc is saying we needed two more weeks
to look at the science look at the data
well the truth is we've given them
billions of dollars the fact that they
can't actually look at the data and
immediately say listen we know that
there's there's a rise in in covet
infections however hospitalizations
haven't spiked this is not that bad take
your mask off and fly little friends fly
yeah judge did you notice how the media
was going after the judge oh absolutely
because she wasn't judged young single
female inexperienced all the all the dog
whistles for sexism all the dog whistles
i mean the fact that you're not
qualified
there you go not qualified that's what
they have american barcelona yeah would
you like to answer it no
don't call me darling i didn't i
say you're sorry i do all right here's
the bottom line because she was a trump
appointee yeah they're furious about it
they can't say anything else the judge
was very clear she said they failed the
the administration failed to adequately
explain their decision there and is the
science argument the mandate exceeded
the statutory authority of the cdc the
judge was very correct on that the cdc
did not have the statutory authority to
mandate that we may wear these masks and
they improperly they didn't do it
properly they were supposed to ask for
notice and comment so everything that
she said was accurate and here's the
bottom line we've got freedom at last if
you don't if you want to wear a mask you
want to muzzle yourself go right ahead
stop bothering me anymore i have freedom
finally we all have the freedom to do
what we want to do and the judge was
absolutely on point and they're mad and
what they're going to do is that
instinct is very strong they're going to
continue to try to embarrass us and
bully us into wearing masks
rally you've been on this planet a while
it seems like there's a flip going on
you would think if you step back it
would have been the republicans and the
le the people who take less fewer risks
would be pro mask and it would be the
freedom-loving liberals you know the you
know burn your bra but it's flipped it's
now the liberals are like we want our
face covered we want to shut down and
it's the it's the true freedom loving
right well imagine how confusing it is
for someone like me in the middle of the
road i have a picture of myself on the
flight today i didn't know what to do
half the people had mass half the people
didn't have mass
they announced it i just saw i decided
to just drape it from my
head
that's quite a brightest nozzle there in
the in the middle of it uh you know i i
think greg to to your point that uh it
all of these decisions are political uh
those we agree with the judge's wise as
we disagree with the judges uh you know
uh is inexperienced and uh incompetent
of this that and the other thing i i
agree with dana i tweeted uh as soon as
i saw her uh her comments on it on
sunday i think it was
you got to go with the flow the judges
decided it was only a couple of weeks
left anyway even in the best of
circumstances so why not
say okay we did what we were supposed to
do and now the judges ruled and let's
move on and you know you want to wear
them you wear you don't want to wear
them you don't want to wear them but it
was it was almost over anyway you know
the what the the masks kind of taught us
we keep talking hearing about racial
divisions and all sorts of divisions
really is a class division we go back to
that met gala
that one image of the powerful unmasked
and all the servants masked i mean i
think we learned that there's an
authentic division in our country and
it's power powerlessness and the the
mask is kind of the symbol and i hope
that that is going to start to lift as
well because that's still happening at
retail shops and at restaurants um
and if it's a personal preference or if
there's a need if there's an
immuno-compromised person that wants to
wear a mask absolutely respect that that
that's not that shouldn't be something
that anyone makes fun of anybody about
but i also think that the white house is
just missing this opportunity to say
this is great america look at look at
how much better we are and when
they could take this opportunity to make
fun of china look at these guys look at
these guys they're having to do all of
these really draconian things while we
have succeeded the country is getting
back to normal yeah
they just miss every opportunity
birthday party too yeah all the guests
there
the servants all get messed up
stop judging it's no the issue is it
feels uncomfortable when someone is
wearing a mask waiting on you and you're
not wearing a mask i'm sorry
psychologically it bothers me it's like
i feel a difference i feel okay that
tells me you are serving me i don't like
that feeling it's interesting you know i
think it's remember pelosi's uh that
dinner party she had and everybody
nobody else had to wear a mask except
for the staff and i don't like it either
it makes me not
there's a particular department store
here i like to go to but i don't like to
go with it no you can't hear anybody
again talk about it
i want to pull it off yeah
what did you say
i can't it's like you can't see their
mouth it's like what did you say
dehumanizing thing it's the face it's
the mouth everything is there on for a
reason so you can continue over now yeah
it's over yeah
says it's over it's over all right hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else